i mean maybe he's confused i'm confused
to be honest yeah maybe he just thinks
he's not well look at that that's
i mean what is that i mean i guess he's
thinking he can move the queen to that
square you said but
what what's he he's even talking to
himself there i think he's confused
either something's happening with the
tech side maybe computer froze mouse
rose or something or he's just confused
about prague's last move and i'm
mightily confused as well the white
queen can just come in i don't really
understand what this last rook move does
for prague
let's maybe take a look at prague as
well
to see his reaction after making this
move
we see the bar has shot up even more as
well yeah it looks like the black rook
which was already offside has gone to a
square that's
not even better uh than it previously
stood
i'm struggling to find what black wants
to do maybe he wants to bring his black
rook across to the f line to look at the
white king but
it's so slow white's queen as we
mentioned is going after those black
pawns immediately yeah i mean he's
yeah i mean he's very